it's been 4 months since we got Apple's
new iPhone 15 lineup and now that all of
the hype has died down I wanted to take
a look at how the regular iPhone 15
models compared to the Pro Models in the
real world covering my top five benefits
that you should expect if you choose to
spend the extra couple hundred first of
all I want to get titanium out of the
way real quick because while the idea of
having a titanium phone sounds really
cool it doesn't really look or feel that
much different compared to a aluminum on
the regular 15 models other than the
added benefit of being a bit more
resistant to scuffs and being lighter
than the previous stainless steel so
don't worry too much about that but
getting into the main benefit number one
we have the cameras now the regular
iPhone 15 does get the same 48 megapixel
camera on paper but in reality the
sensor size itself is larger on the Pro
Models which leads to better camera
quality especially in low light since it
can take in more light while snapping
photos and recording videos but the big
benefit is the telephoto camera which
gives it a huge Advantage you get so
much freedom and flexibility by being
able to zoom in optically instead of
digitally which doesn't look great now
3x on the 15 pro model is good giving
you much higher quality with zoom shots
but the new 5x camera on the pro Max is
a game changer
this camera by itself allowed us to
record very high quality footage from a
distance at our recent CES trip where we
visited tons of different boots and shot
videos showcasing multiple Brands and
the quality of the close-up 5x video was
just awesome and plus the 5x camera has
a very unique 120 mm focal length which
gives it a pro camera look which you
can't easily replicate on any other
smartphone and looking back at our CES
footage it's really quite surprising
that we shot everything with three
iPhone 15 Pro Maxes now the quality of
the 5x lens itself is outstanding with
an f2.8 aperture which is unheard of in
the smartphone space because everybody
else is using Periscope lenses apple is
using a tetr prism lens which gives you
two massive advantages Advantage number
one is that you get much better quality
in low or dim light so it doesn't have
to raise the iso as high leading to an
overall cleaner and Sharper Image
Advantage number two is that you
actually get three-way stabilization for
the first time ever on a telephoto
camera like this you get up and down
side toide and in and out stabilization
this is by far the most stable telephoto
lens that I've ever seen and now let's
move on to benefit number two which is
the USBC Port now all of the iPhone 15
models have USBC ports which has been an
awesome experience allowing you to
connect various accessories hubs and
even hooking it up to my projector to
play games using an Xbox controller but
the benefit for the 15 Pro Models is
that the transfer speed is actually 20
times faster than on the regular 15
models 10 gbits per second instead of
only 480 megabits per second which is
huge and we experienced this in the real
world on our CES trip last week since we
were recording all of the video onto our
iPhones after the first day of shooting
we came back to our hotel and did what
we would usually do we tried to airdrop
the video footage from our iPhones onto
the MacBooks so that we could organize
it and then transfer it to this little
SSD that we brought so we could transfer
and split up the workload across each of
our MacBooks but then came the
realization that the iPhone 15 Pro now
has a fast USBC port and we could
literally just transfer the files to the
SSD plugged in directly so I tried it
out and I kid you not it transferred so
fast that I thought that it actually
failed or errored out but upon checking
the folder in the SSD every single clip
was there and it just felt so surreal
that it transferred that quickly without
any issues at all so our editing
workflow was so simple and quick and it
was all thanks to the new new 10 GBS per
second USBC port on the iPhone 15 Pro
Models which is finally fast and
functional enough to make the iPhone
usable as your main video shooting
device which we proved with a jam-packed
filming schedule at CES and while we're
on the topic of the awesome new USBC
Port I want to show you guys the best
gaming controller for USBC iPhones and
Androids from our sponsor gam sir this
is the G V8 Galileo Mobile gaming
controller which is designed to give you
the most comfortable gaming experience
you can get by simply extending the
controller and plugging your iPhone into
the convenient movable type-c port and
Bam you instantly have a console
controller feel and experience packed
with dual holif effect joysticks
triggers and buttons two of which are
programmable on the backside it supports
pass through charging and 3.5 mm audio
with replaceable face plates and thumb
sticks and it just made my gaming
experience a 100 times better and I
highly recommend it so go ahead and
check it out using the link in the
description and pinned comment below and
now getting into benefit number three we
have performance the new iPhone 15 Pro
Models get the a17 pro chip now at first
when this came out we were worried about
the overheating issues and the battery
life drainage which was a problem but
after Apple's big update months ago
we've had no issues at all overheating
has completely disappeared and the
battery life is incredible just like it
was before and we can now enjoy more
performance than ever what shocked me
was when I literally tried to get it to
overheat and have the display brightness
dim down like it always did in the past
but to my shock it didn't dim whatsoever
while playing various games in the
office even 20 FPS games which was so
impressive that I just couldn't
comprehend how Apple was doing this now
on top of that the iPhone 15 Pro Models
also come with 8 GB of RAM compared to 6
which I believe is finally the number
where I no longer notice any trouble
multitasking with various apps and I no
longer have any apps closing down and
having to start fresh over again I mean
this has the same amount of ram as you
get in the Bas M3 MacBook Pro for pizza
sake so it's finally enough and overall
the general performance has been
incredible with no slowdowns whatsoever
across the board now getting into the
main benefit number four we have the
action button now when this first came
out I wasn't sure what to do with it so
I figured I could just use it to open up
the camera app quickly to take photos or
record videos however I found myself
just using the previous method of
opening the camera app with this little
button because my fingers just got used
to it over the years so I thought the
action button was a waste of time in a
gimmick but for the past couple of
months I've actually been loving the
action button now that I switched it
over to opening the Tesla app it's just
so convenient instead of having to
unlock my phone find the app and get in
it just happens instantly no matter
which app you're in or if your phone is
even unlocked or on the lock screen it
just opens right up and I love how Apple
designed it so you you can do basically
anything you want even fully
customizable shortcuts now I thought
this was a gimmick at first but now I
find myself using it all the time it's
just such a convenient little button
especially now that it's winter and it's
freezing cold outside it allows me to
quickly open up the app and turn on my
heater so I think Apple did a great job
and now finally for benefit number five
we have all of the other exclusive
additional features that add value now
first of all I seriously cannot get over
the 120hz promotion display technology
that's exclusive to the Pro Models that
makes it feel so smooth that I don't
think I would ever be able to switch
back to a regular iPhone just because of
that feature alone that by itself makes
a bigger performance and snappiness
difference than any chip has ever seemed
to make doubling the refresh rate it
just feels so quick and snappy now on
top of that the new iPhone 15 pro model
also come with Wi-Fi 6E which you can't
get on the regular 15s which has given
me a noticeable boost to the reliability
of Wi-Fi inside of my house and it seems
like all of the signals in general are
now having higher strength compared to
before on top of that it comes with 256
gigs of storage instantly adding $100 of
value so just including all of the
exclusive features that you get makes it
clear that it's worth spending the extra
cash if you have it so with all that
said after 4 months I've got to say that
the benefits that you get with the Pro
Models instead of the regular 15s are so
worth it especially in terms of the
cameras and the faster USBC Port so
hopefully you enjoy this video and if
you did go ahead and subscribe above and
click that Circle right over there for
more videos like this
[Music]
one